I don't like any of our videos after a
while I look back and go oh that's
that's all right I just have a
relationship with the music that's made
and then when it's someone else's vision
goes on it it's like I wasn't thinking
about it even if it's my idea because
there's a couple of the videos over the
years even the worst ones what's the
worst one you think we had this one
video where he's playing that oh that
video is amazing it's called my lady got
two men yeah yeah and it's the one we
made it look like it's a song from the
70s
make art together that's already a
collaboration right I have a vision of
what it is he has a vision we see
different colors sometimes when we're
doing it we have different ideas of what
it is but we both know hey it means a
lot to both of us let's let other people
hear it well then sometimes you make a
video for those now you trusting another
person to have this Vision to go with it
and when you tie their Vision to yours
it can be real difficult if you take
yours serious or if you nurture it the
way that that we do you know what I mean
so it's like it could be difficult to I
have to disconnect the two yeah how is
this video If this wasn't mine would I
watch it again